non du tout dans mon ange et un grand
pur qui joué du piston mais c'est le
seul c'est le seul élément artistique de
la famille su comment avez vous fait
pour entraver comédie française écoutez
j'ai suivi une filière normale entre au
conservatoire en 44 et en 46 j'étais
démissionné du conservatoire pour ne pas
dire fichu à la porte pour des raisons
disciplinaires
c'est à peu près ça et ça m'a permis de
faire un an de boulevard et de
d'attendre un tout petit peu mais
j'avais quand même beaucoup d'amitié
encore gardés au conservatoire et déjà
un petit peu entré au cac de français et
j'ai une demande d'audition juin 47 et
j'ai passé l'audition donc je rentrais
sur auditions au théâtre français les
pièces disciplinés comme ça
l'indiscipliné de tourner un film
d'ailleurs un très mauvais film et ça en
congé sans autorisation de 2 du
directeur doit les aventures de tes
potes là et alors c'était très drôle
parce que lui venait d'entrer en
fonctions après la guerre en 44 après la
libération 44 et dix ans plus tard moi
je les retrouvais alors lui été mise à
la retraite de l'adhésion et moi j'étais
au jury du conservatoire j'ai trouvé ça
assez rigolo c'était pas un film dont
une télépathe est un film dans une
capote et moi c'était très mauvais alors
d'ailleurs ça a changé mon destin nous a
si le film a été bon choix peut-être
jamais entretien français trouvaient
plus concédé que c'était pas bon on n'a
pas regardé parce que vous savez que
vous n'aviez pas deux heures de perdues
à quel âge est ce que vous êtes rentré
la comédie française
bah écoutez le de mon contrat est parti
du 1er septembre 47 donc j'avais
22 ans et 11 mois et pourquoi avez vous
quitté la comédie française est bien
pour beaucoup de raisons d'abord je ne
crois pas qu'on puisse faire maintenant
nos jours une carrière total de la vie
entière au théâtre français sont très
jeunes et mettons si dieu vous accorde
50 ans de carrière ça fait donc 73 ans
et je crois pas que je puisse continuer
à jouer comédie jusque là je semble
présenter à 30 et dans de bonnes
conditions
je pense pour moi et par rapport à un
public alors ça c'est une raison
je crois qu'il faut un très jeune ou
alors à l'âge de la maturité faire un
parcours de 25 ou 30 ans cetera cap
leucate france et la force du théâtre
français c'est d'avoir si vous voulez à
sa disposition une réserve acteurs
constante et il est normal que sans
qu'on cède la place aux jeunes c'est
parce que je veux dire du tout mais que
les jeunes vous pose un tout petit peu
alors je crois qu'il faut partir avant
d'être poussé dehors
et puis vous mais précédé l'événement
que le subir c'est une autre raison qui
alors il ya une troisième raison c'est
que je crois qu'un tout homme dans sa
vie ça vous arrivera à vous aussi à un
instant de confrontation avec lui-même
en fait une espèce de bilan avec le
masque qu'il a fait ce qu'il a envie de
faire ce qui n'a pas encore fait ce
qu'il a réussi ce qui n'a pas réussi et
j'avais l'impression d'être d'avoir
atteint français une certaine limitation
j'avais l'impression que je rejoue et
les mêmes rôles ce cyrano figaro et
styrax sont très beau rôle mais j'avais
un besoin de création et surtout de de
me prouver à moi même que je pouvais
faire autre chose et je ne dis pas mieux
ou plus mal je ne sais pas mais autre
chose
alors j'avais une immense curiosité vers
l'extérieur vers d'autres rencontres
d'autres rencontres d'auteurs de metteur
en scène c est après avoir vraiment je
vous jure beaucoup réfléchi j'ai sauté
le pas je suis parti vous avez dit à
l'ats le roi que lou rtf ne possédait
pas de documents sur vos pièces de
théâtre
et nous nous avons trouvé dans la
cinémathèque doit retrouver finalement
des documents que vous ne connaissez
peut-être pas assez bien pousser de
fausses confidences à la tendance malgré
l'essai non jeu que je savais que ça
existe et je n'ai pas vu marques dont on
vous cherche pour vous montrer
l'appartement quand vous destine lugrin
est allé boire j'ai dit que j'allais
vous avertir comment voudrais tu tombes
et les thémas suis enchanté de quelle
façon telle reçu ce que tu lui as dit
elle opine tout doucement à vous garder
par compassion
elle espère vous guérir par l'habitude
de la voir sincèrement elle n'en
réchappera pâte autant de prix je me
retourne presque au contraire je crois
aussi marton dis-lui que madame ma temps
pour me remettre des papiers et que
j'irai la trouver dès que je les aurai
mort par t si bien et jean petit avis à
donner à marc temps et il est bon de
jeter dans tous les esprits les soupçons
dont nous avons besoin
oui il me sembla pas bien avec toi
il dit que mam l'attend pour lui
remettre des papiers il reviendra
ensuite au risque est il nécessaire
qu'ils voient cet appartement s'il en
voulait pas il serait bien délicat par
dix je lui conseillerais ils sont partis
d'affaires je suis les ordres de madame
madame est bonne et sage mais prenez
garde
ne trouvez-vous pas que ce petit gars là
lui fait les yeux doux
il est fait comme il les a je me trompe
forces et j'ai pas vu la mine de ce
freluquet considéré je ne sais où celle
de madame bien ce qu'on te fasse quand
on la trouve belle non mais je me figure
quelque fois qu'il est venu ici pour le
voir de plus près l idée battu n'y
entend rien tu connais mal si l'on vient
l'original avec les observations
allez allez prenez toujours je reste je
ne voulais faire trouver meilleur allons
faire jouer toutes nos patries
à quelle année se situe ce passage sas
est cette émission là oui c'est les
fausses confidences c'est dans le cadre
des émissions que le cas de france est
organisé pour le rtf en collaboration
avec l'ouverture à l'oeil on s'était
fait donc au théâtre c'est pas du tout
fait en studio c'est dans le décor même
de la pièce transporte transporté à
l'odéon provisoirement transformé en
studio donc ça doit monter seulement 73
savoir ça doit être chiant 71
ah oui c'est très stressant vie vous
arrive-t-il d'avoir le trac
il m'arrive souvent d'avoir le trac oui
je crois que c'est un phénomène
inévitable puis je crois même
souhaitable parce que ce qui est
important dans notre métier si vous
voulez c'est l'émotion qu'on peut
ressentir quelques quelques pièces qu'on
puisse jouer comique ou dans toute l'île
tragique c'est l'émotion qu'on peut
ressentir a présenté pour la première
fois devant un public ce qu'on peut
appeler tout de même pour un acteur une
création d'un personnage et cette
création suscite une émotion ce qu'on
appelle le trac et elle est
indispensable ya des acteurs rare
d'ailleurs qu'ils n'ont pas le trac et
bien et je crois qu'il leur manque
quelque chose je peux pas vous dire que
ce tract continue à mesure que la
plantation s'écoule à la 50e d'une pièce
on a plus le trac du tout en tout cas ça
peut revenir
certaines dérives des enduits d'ailleurs
là on se prend les pieds dans le tapis
régulièrement m'enfin au premier où on a
le trac et c'est un phénomène à
dispenser un extrait de ruy blas parce
qu'il ya eu d'horribles asma j'ai fait
un bruit place avec barma il ya une
dizaine d'années le voilà ah non ça
c'est celui de raymond rouleau enfin
celui de celui que raymond rouleau avait
fait avec la comédie française
depuis il faut par quelques plans
terrible et merveilleux tu n'es pas que
je pense un aveu scrupuleux me venger
orange est oui
de qui d'une femme ne me dit pas plus
sur mon âme mon coussin en ceci pas là
mon sentiment
teulé qui bassement est tortueuse mans
se venge ayant le droit de porter une
lame noble par une intrigue sommes sur
une femme et qui les gentilhommes
agitons alguazil plus futiles grand de
castille [ __ ] il est suivi de son
clairon sonne ont des pattes a marre le
tilt war nash est d'ordre et de chamarré
marquis et vicomte et fils des anciens
pr n'est pour moi qu'un marc aux
sinistrés ténébreux que je voudrais pour
prix de sa lâcheté ville pourra revendre
à 4 cluj iv de la ville césar ajouté pas
un mot cet outrage en garde est votre
secret et gardez votre argent
je comprends qu'on tue et convoler
compris que par une nuit noire on force
le pastis d'assaut la hache au point
avec sans fil bustier qu'on égorgeait
staff y est jolie et qui est douce
saillantes et hurlant bandits que nous
sommes il pourra le temps pour danser
bien homme contre homme mais doucement
détruire une femme est creusée sous
cette ligne de tram est contre elle
abuse et qui sait de son humeur
peut-être au hasard deux prendre ce
pourvoi zoo dans quelques pluies deux
jours plus tôt karim et jusqu'à ce
déshonneur plutôt qu'être à ce prix un
riche et au seigneur et je le dis ici
pour dieu qui voit mon âme
j'aimerais mieux plutôt qu'être à ce
point infâme ville odieux pervers
misérables et flétrie qu'un chien ronge
à mon crâne au pied du pylône cousins
vont bien fait je n'aurais nulle envie
tant que je trouverai vivent ma libre
vis aux fontaines de l'eau dans les
champs le grand air à la ville un voleur
qui m'habite l'hiver dans mon âme
l'oubli dé prospérité mortes et devant
vos palais que de larges portes aux jeux
puis à midi sans souci du réveil dormir
la tête à l'ombre les pieds au soleil
radieux dans de nous de dieu sait quel
est le juste avec les gens le cours vos
pareils on salue ce je vous laisse et je
reste avec mes chenapans je vis avec les
loups non avec les serpents à
l'installer m abrégeant la visite c'est
comme envoyer en prison fait vite un nom
je vous croyais assez influent durci
l'épreuve vous et bonne épouse a réussi
je suis content de vous votre main je
vous prie comment je n'ai parlé que par
plaisanterie tout ce que j'ai dis là
c'est pour vous éprouvez rien de plus ça
veut bout vous me fait rêver
la femme le complot cette vengeance leur
imagination chimère
la définition du clochard sa sublime
c'est poétique
c2c du 19e siècle aux clochards bas si
on doit me go certain ça devait
certainement exister bien sûr pendant la
pièce qui vous a rendu ses lèvres
si c'est pas mademoiselle d'abord je
vous savez célébrité est un mot qu une
qui me fait quelque chose de 2,2 non
c'est instamment inacceptable mais je
crois qu'une carrière c'est fait d'une
certaine somme de deux rôles de
rencontres avec des pièces et serra et
alors je ne pense pas qu'ils aient
quelque chose qui me rendue célèbre
si vous voulez je sais que la télévision
est un moyen de 2 2
connaissance toute célébrité et normes
de divulgation du nom et d'un et d'une
oeuvre et d'un acteur énorme donc
évidemment la première fois j'avais la
télévision avec une série qui s'appelle
lagardère ça donnait des résultats
importants mais la célébrité est un
phénomène très provisoire équine qui a
besoin sans arrêt dans notre carrière et
dans toutes les carrières d'ailleurs de
confirmation alors il n'y a pas eu un
rôle si vous voulez ya eu oui peut-être
une marche d'escalier au tiers de
français qui a fait je suis sortie d'un
certain anonymat c'était cyrano parce
que ça roule très populaire et dans
l'est une pièce elle-même très populaire
donc ça évidemment provoqué quelque
chose puis ensuite cette série qu'elle
faisait allusion et mais si vous voulez
je crois que une grande carrière c'est
une guerrière qui dans l'accomplissement
va loin dans le temps dans la ferraille
avec des des petits brevet de confiance
comme ça que la vie vous accorde à
travers un rôle ou une pièce one film
télévision
monsieur b rose qui voudrais vous poser
une question et bien sûr quelle est la
pièce qui vous a le plus plu que vous
avez joué dans votre carrière
c'est aussi difficile de vous répondre
c'est un petit peu comme si vous me
demandez quel est le livre qui
m'intéresse le plus ce qui me touche le
plus
je vous répondrai très directement je
croyais sincèrement ce que j'aime le
plus jouer c'est ce que je joue à
l'instant où je le joue actuellement je
joue une pièce françoise dorin ça n'a
aucun rapport avec ce que j'ai fait mais
j'aime beaucoup jouer ça parce que c'est
une pièce comique et ducasse en veste
ans que je n'ai pas fait depuis
longtemps où pratiquement jamais c'est
un succès important donc je suis très
heureux de jouer ça par contre il est
certain que on a mieux joué deux très
beaux rôles et des choses qui marquent
évidemment donc cyrano donc l'hommage
figaro même les fausses confidences que
j'ai mis en scène et joué c'est ça m'a
procuré de grands noms mais pas y'a pas
eu un rôle qui m'a plus particulièrement
attiré non maintenant nous allons voir
une séquence des rois maudits
oui qu'elle contribue justement c'est
oui c'est le deuxième phase et cette
notoriété ces réseaux
je suis le comte robert d'artois robert
beaucoup oui votre cousin à mesdames et
votre serviteur et voyez mon cousin ce
qu'on a fait de nous même pas à siéger à
offrir un seigneur de votre point
capitaine monseigneur ya donc pas de feu
ici dans mon seigneur mais qu'on a en
face il est meuble où sont ils j'avais
des ordres y en a d'autres à l'idée fais
des flambeaux et vite et amant sait
comment à manger mais bien sûr des pâtes
et des rhodes et légumes frais de bonnes
poires divers et les confitures et du
vin bon coup de main et monseigneur mais
il est sourd ou quoi monseigneur
[Applaudissements]
marguerite beaux cheveux quoi mais chez
deux sont ils bien fourni à nouveau
que faut-il vous montrer d'autres mon
cousin mais je ne voulais pas vous à
penser ma cousine simplement savoir si
vos cheveux et est revenu assez long
pour que vous puissiez vous présenter au
monde et tous venus me dire
je suis venu vous délivrer un message et
qu'ils de louis votre époux notre roi
désormais et de notre bon cousin
monseigneur de valois mais j'ai un ordre
de ne parler qu'à vous seul certes je
vais me retirer mais auparavant mon
cousin seulement
oui charles mon mari que pense-t-il émoi
depuis pontoise on ne l'a jamais vu gay
comme avant je crois qu'il vous regrette
en dépit de ce qu'il a souffert par
l'eau
pensez vous qu'ils me pardonnent
ça dépend beaucoup de votre cousine
et bien pour terminer on fait une petite
surprise
nous allons voir un extrait de cyrano de
bergerac petite surprise d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui qu'elle n'était pas au
courant que vous êtes déjà bien cyrano
j'emmène c'est vrai qu'on vient de voir
ça c'est la première fois qu'on va nous
regarder parfois la mer ensemble de
quelques grappes mans vous à courrier
alors jouant à la maman je disais d'une
voix qui tâcher d'être dur qu'est ce que
c'est encore que cette égratignures
c'est trop fort et celle ci montre il
veut tu rajoutes et tu fais cela un jour
du côté de la porte de belles si
gentiment aussi gaiement maternelle mais
dites moi pendant que jose un peu le
sens il était contre vous ont pas tout à
fait sans comptes n'ont laissé mais vous
dites la chose que vous n'osiez tantôt
me dire à présent jose car le passé mot
courage à de son parfum
oui j'ose maintenant voilà j'aime
quelqu'un
qui ne le sait pas d'ailleurs pas encore
mais qui va bientôt le savoir s'ils
l'ignorent
pauvre garçon qui jusqu'ici mais ma
timidement de loin sans oser le dire
laissez-moi patron de la voyons et de la
fièvre mais moi j'ai vu trembler les
oeuvres sur scène et figurez vous tenez
que justement
oui mon cousin une serre dans votre
régiment puisqu'il est cadet dans votre
compagnie et là c'est son fond de
l'esprit du génie il est fier loeb
jeunes intrépides beau se dire que c'est
elle a dû être pris au début des
représentations 64 le premier né il
fallait tout ay marie huriez oui oui oui
sûrement si je manquais pas du tout
satisfait la salut tu fais pour une
nature comment vous vous trouvez
sincèrement je trop jeune trop je trouve
le visage trop lisse je voudrais vous
contrer ce très jeune premier et
d'allouer oui c'était la première
version du premier né après ça un peu
gonflé je trouve que ça manque
d'hôpitaux rsa monte de 2 de puissance
et ça c'est très frais avaient encore du
figaro dans ses magasins mais je crois
d'ailleurs que la scène je jouais plus
puissamment que ça se sent qu'il ya une
espèce de limitation d'aider des moyens
à cause de la caméra et c'est du propre
ce soit mauvais sujets n'ont cessé pour
ça manque de couleurs sans jeu de mots
une question encore mon but
cette joué longtemps bien sûr mais si
vous voulez c'est de ne pas perdre une
certaine image de marque c'est à dire
que je voudrais autant que possible de
garder une certaine qualité dans les
choix
ça c'est très important je voudrais
tenir le coup dans ce domaine pose est
poussé par des nécessités précise tenir
un certain certes un certain rang et une
certaine qualité dans ce rang quoi ne
pas ne pas me laisser aller à des cieux
jeu c'est quelquefois pas facile enfin
parce qu'il faut vous mais quelquefois
attendre deux ans avant de jouer une
pièce plutôt qu'un jouet n'est pas très
bonne
avez vous aider à vous avez vous déjà
été sifflées ou et à oui ça m'est arrivé
mais c'était accidentel ce 6ème est un
comédien farceur je peux dire son nom si
des villes de courtois avec qui ils
écoutent l'émission salle à buzeins ce
cochon l'un faisait rire en scène
d'alain shakespeare qui s'appelle compte
direct debit pièce laisserait les gérer
comique de shakespeare enfin les acteurs
sont pas priés de rire quand il joue un
shakespeare et c'était un terrible 7 un
terrible blagueur et des trucs raconter
des trucs pendant pendant que je
racontais mon texte et puis je me suis
éclatée gré à tout d'un coup il ya un
cycle etc est parti en piètre français
je sais plus quel étage mais pas
tellement ni à leur caisse était plus
tolérant un peu élevé mais je vous
serais parti comme ça j'ai eu
l'impression de recevoir une gifle de
rappel terrible c'était vraiment très
dur des jantes encore le son du disciple
il ya 15 ans ou 20 ans ça ça va être
extrêmement brutale est pire que 10 des
services du régisseur publié de service
puis c'est utile parce que je crois que
c'est une chose qu'on ne doit pas on
doit pas se laisser aller à cette chose
là on peut placer ces aléas ça arrive
quand on joue en personne
[Musique]